when people and police are armed
policing in america doesn't always look
like this
let me see our hands hands hands don't
go nowhere
a situation defuse not with weapons but
with words
hey it's everybody now hands let me see
your hands
don't move
[Music]
in newark new jersey the police have a
soft new facade
bingo with locals one way to build
bridges
this force was once deemed so corrupt
and so violent the government had to
intervene
events like this yielding impact instead
of being met with anger
okay they're welcomed that's the
difference
sweeping reforms here have changed
things community outreach better
training and new rules around
force not a single shot was fired here
by officers last year
it's a remarkable feat on the streets of
america but problems persist
black people still disproportionately
stopped and subjected to force
when we first started implementing body
cameras and new use of force
uh policies and trainings the reaction
was
literally from some of the senior
officers here that i was personally
going to get a cop
killed in this city because of the
cameras and cops being afraid to act and
the new policy and so on and
today now that's the opposite is what
you've done here
enough i don't believe that it's ever
possible to do enough i mean i think
it's something
honestly it's something i worry about
every day it's always possible for
any human being to make a bad decision
and no one knows that better than abdul
malik
police here may not have shot anyone in
2020 but it was just new year's day when
they killed his stepson carl dorsey
yet more fuel to the feeling that not
enough's changed
when he left out that night he should
have had the right to come back home to
his family
do you think policing in this area is
good enough as a black man
in america you can't trust the police
you know you have to you know
maybe have some faith in them that
they're going to do the right thing
and their job is to you know protect and
serve you etc
but trust i can't say that
there's hope that george floyd's case
might meaningfully move the dial when it
comes to policing in america but it will
take much longer
to change how communities perceive it
even here where there's been real
political will
time and money behind change for many
decades of injustice mean that
resentment
still runs very deep for larry the
answer is more accountability
he's campaigned for it here for five
decades it's not just the police
it's the whole damn system that needs to
be changed
you're not going to see an appreciable
decline in police brutality
until the police understand that they're
going to be prosecuted for their crimes
just like the average citizen
that's something the biden
administration would like to see too but
police legislation
still fiercely resisted this city may be
a model but reform nationwide won't be
easy
many hope this moment in history can be
harnessed the passion for change not
passed by
helen smith sky news newark new jersey